if i have this right you were supposed
to do this show last year
and didn't and now you finally are right
he's cha-cha into the ballroom say hello
to brian austin green what made you
change your mind
my
don't girlfriend so what'd she say no
she didn't say anything
it was we had a we had a great
conversation when we first started
dating because the idea of doing this
show for me
i had already said no to doing this for
a while
so we talked about the fact that like
this is never gonna happen
um
and now here i am so a
never say never
that's lesson one
important and
uh i decided to really do this because
she's so passionate about dancing and i
felt like this is a great way for us to
really
learn about each other more and for me
to understand her side of it so uh we'll
see i may not stick around very long i'm
i'm honestly trying to set the bar as
low as i possibly can i said that over
there and he thought i was joking but
i'll it you'll hear it more than once
i'm sure the bar is on the floor the bar
is on the floor for me so so well that
that is really nice there are no
expectations i mean i did also wonder
was part of it that if you didn't say
yes she was going to go in the
quarantine bubble and you weren't going
to see her for a minute no no no no that
wasn't that that wasn't an issue at all
no
it's uh
she's
she's been dancing her whole life this
is really she's so passionate about it
and has such a
deep love for it which i understand i'm
passionate about so many things in my
own life and so it's a it's just this is
an amazing opportunity to connect with
somebody and to
really
try and understand that as much as i
possibly can in
10 episodes of of a show well it's it's
the boot camp to do it for sure it is
the boot camp to do it i mean i i love
hearing this i saw on her instagram the
other day she posted a super cute
picture of you guys and she captioned it
end game yes what does that mean
it it actually didn't mean
it end game means you guys are each
other's end game
okay well that's okay so that's your
definition
i don't know did you see the movie end
game because everybody died so it's i
think we don't want to go that way i
think they're are different levels of
the word there are different definitions
of the word endgame okay what did it
mean for that she
it's we we are both in something right
now that is it's an end game for i mean
that's the goal is you you try and stay
with somebody as long as you possibly
can hopefully forever so that's that's
our goal in this situation there was
nothing more to it i know people read
into it a little bit and it's been
talked about a bit yeah as you just
brought up i mean it's on it's on
instagram yeah i mean you know people
are talking about it
so uh but you guys are in love you're
happy yeah yeah very happy she's amazing
oh that's i don't know if you've ever
gotten a chance to i've interviewed her
many
times and she's so talented and her
choreography is next level
so how excited are you to experience
that because
i mean i'm guessing you guys are
partners
no see you're you're
i i'm i
i
am not going to confirm nor deny that
um
we talk about it okay when i'm not
rehearsing and she gives me pointers
so i'll give you that much so you're not
partners i again i am not confused okay
then walk me through this when you just
when you talked about doing the show did
you discuss that and what did you see as
the pros or cons of being or not being
partners with each other
um
[Music]
there weren't really any cons
to it
um
you're getting excited see i'm giving
you something here
[Laughter]
pros to being partners
pros
the pros to being partners
obviously because we know each other so
well and there's chemistry there so that
would be a huge positive
um
but you're just gonna have to watch the
show to find out i don't know we're not
gonna give you anything i know but
here's i mean i do the [ __ ] i understand
that you're i know here and i've got the
e.t mic in my hand and i'm supposed to
give you something
but that's not gonna happen i'm not a
rookie i've been doing this for a while
i know i mean but i cover the show every
season and what people say is it's
stressful it all is so i so there is
that question of like if you you know if
you did it together is it i love that
you're saying we thought it would be
amazing it would bring us closer but
there's a stress element to it there is
yeah
yeah it's what are how are you feeling
about the journey you're about to go on
the toll on you on your body on your
mental state
that one of my number one goals is to
not hurt myself yeah because i want to
continue acting afterwards
and moving i've like young boys and so i
like i have to be active
by the way what do they think about dad
doing dancing with the stars i love it
they do love it yeah yeah they they
really like the show and they want to
because i don't dance much at home just
because again don't want to hurt myself
um so they'll be in the audience they
they'll be in the audience at some point
oh that was awesome yeah um people had
wanted you to do this show for so long
yes um have you heard from any of your
uh fellow actors or 902 alum about you
doing it no because we just did this
today this is the first
so this has been one of the like big
stressful things for me is keeping all
of this under wraps and everything so
now being able to do this and talk about
oh hey i'm doing the show is like oh now
people will know because i haven't
verified anything will you reach out to
any of them for advice a lot of 90210
people have done the show i'm sure i
will okay be like how do i get through
this um okay
what have i signed up for what what have
i gotten myself in how am i going to
live through this
um and uh last how have rehearsals been
going so far
rehearsals have been good it's it's it's
a lot of information for for someone
that has never done
partner
ballroom dancing it's a lot it's it's
not like when i was younger and i used
to go to clubs and dance
can we incorporate some of the 90s moves
huh how about some of your club moves i
want to see some other no they're not
they're all online you can find all of
them
i don't need to show you now because
they're not nearly as good as they were
back then
[Music]
you